it's friday night and that means it's
time for
well it's friday follies a radical
priest tries to rehab
farrakhan a panel of democrats fight
over 2020 and one dad
you want to avoid in the field joining
us now with all the details
raymond arroyo fox news contributor of
course will wilder
author raymond i thought after farrakhan
was
banned from facebook that i don't know
his days in the spotlight might be
coming to an end
but now a catholic priest
is trying to resurrect him laura
it's simply unbelievable chicago priest
father michael flager
a leftist activist which we'll get into
in a moment yeah he invited the
controversial nation of islam leader to
speak
at his chicago parish yesterday
the reason he wants farrah khan back on
facebook watch
minister farah khan
has been a bold voice against injustice
done against black people in this
country his voice deserves
and needs to be heard
to underscore the point flager broadcast
louis farrakhan's visit from his parish
on facebook
flouting their ban even though farrakhan
was banned from the social media site
in part because of his allegedly
anti-semitic speech
to the white people
who think i'm a hater you don't know me
but somebody made you hate
me this is just the beginning
banning me from a social platform
i use that platform
with respect and i'm here to separate
the good jews
from the satanic jews
laura this man he's out of his mind and
and for flager to think that this is
appropriate
or in any way social justice to bring
a man like this spouting hatred and
anti-semitism
to a catholic church frankly it's
amazing to me that the chicago
archdiocese hasn't intervened here lord
outrageous flager has been doing this
nonsense
this type of stuff raymond for years and
yet
the vatican looks the other way there's
no comment he
the flager has been a a a a nightmare
frankly for
a lot of catholics in the chicago area
and and frankly across the country for a
long long time
we should we should have brought flager
on our our facebook panel that we had
a few minutes ago maybe he here's the
thing he
at one point flaker said america is the
greatest sin
it's the greatest sin against god and he
called for a gun owner who owned a shop
he asked people to snuff out the owner
of the gun shop i mean
now the president of the illinois
holocaust museum fritzi fritzell
herself a survivor of the holocaust said
today quote
i don't understand father flager because
i've always thought he was one for peace
what he's doing today and what he's
doing with farrakhan
is giving him a platform for hatred hey
tritty has spoken for many many years
laura this is just the beginning of this
and and hopefully it's not the last we
hear
of people speaking out against this kind
of hatred but flakers should be ashamed
all right tell us about this cnn panel
what what what
well speaking of unexpected reactions
cnn gathered a panel of democrats in
pennsylvania
to try to get a pulse on how democrats
are feeling going into 2020
then came the ultimate question
how many of you feel confident today
that a democrat will win in 2020.
later a fight broke out it was crickets
laura the only two of them raise their
hand
well later a fight over the gender of
the democratic nominee
or what it should be what i still don't
know if the country's ready for a woman
we want to think
they are but i'm not convinced but does
that mean one's gonna be ready now we
have to make
it ready it's time for a woman to run
this country yes
why not i want a woman president more
than anything else in this world
when i was a little girl i wanted to be
the first woman president
that's nice well first of all
what i'm still trying to get over is
allison camarada
saying this raymond after only two or
three people raised
hands about whether they're profiting
hmm
who did this wait wait who picked the
composition of this panel what producer
is going to get the boot because of this
embarrassing cnn
but laura you saw something very
illustrative there
you are seeing a glimpse of 2020 in the
democratic party
at the moment they lack unity there is
no clear governing agenda or something
to rally them together
except hatred of trump that's it but
what you see what you're seeing
and what i think you're going to see
more of is a collapse into gender and
and
uh identity politics that could rip them
apart and really
they could have be a multi-headed hydra
going into 2020
and pave the way for donald trump no
okay now laura i got a mess
we've been having some very bad weather
down here in louisiana where i am now
and the other day a local reporter
lester dewey
decided to use a prop to show how high
the water was
he decided to use a crawfish bad choice
and a number of people are actually here
looking for crawfish okay just
got me actually on tv okay well that
hurt
laura if the only good kind of crawfish
is one that's been boiled when you snap
its head off that's it that's the only
kind that you're
right i thought it was going to be like
the other day when that man r
rung the doorbell and then the snake bit
him this was sold to me as a crawfish
fish biting a nose like i wanted the no
no no
not just a finger what is that getting
us the finger it is
we want the whole nose taken off okay
not not really
it's just funnier no no no laura i have
a big book signing here in new orleans
before i go
tomorrow saturday at octavia books
uptown 3 p.m
i'll be signing copies of the world
wilder series so everybody come out and
see me raymondorio.com details are there
see you next week all right raymond
we'll see you next week